ALI AFSHAR: Thanks for coming.
Please obviously
leave if you--
no, I'm kidding.
So, thank you everyone
for coming today.
Really good to see you all.
Today, I'm going to be talking
about using Google Drive as
the storage solution
on Android.
We're not going to be breaking
the bounds of modern science.
I'm going to talk to you about
files and where you can put
them and where you
should put them.
Personally, I think Drive is
the perfect solution for
Android, and I'm going to
tell you why, obviously.
I'm in love.
There's a heart for me.
That's really great.
What would you do with this?
You would allow your users to
have seamless, cross-device,
cross-platform,
cross-application cross-user
experiences.
Sorry that was a big run
through, but that's the
essential point of it.
If you do that for people,
they will be happy.
Put the user first, focus
on the user, and
the rest will follow.
That's our goal here, keep
the users happy.
If I can jump straight into a
use case, this is a personal
situation I had.
I have a child.
I'm quite a paranoid
parent, and I like
taking data about things.
There are plenty of applications
for Android for
various handheld devices
that collect baby data.
Can you imagine every time your
baby does a poop, you
record it, every time your baby
has a nap, you record it,
every time any biological
function you could imagine,
medicine, this kind of thing.
So there are loads of these
applications, lots
and lots and lots.
And I went through them one by
one and I found what I thought
was a really good one.
It's called Baby ESP, and it is
a really great application.
It's perfect for the use case.
When you install it, you have
to set up some information.
So at the start, I set in the
name of the child, the date of
birth, these kind of things,
and that's the
configuration it needs.
And you can see along the top
there-- these are screenshots
from the actual application--
I removed all the data.
So you can track information
about your baby.
You can see at the top there,
they've got nursing and
sleeping and diapers and
this kind of thing.
So really great.
Has everything I need.
This is an example.
You record a session.
It tells you how long it
was, what it involved.
You can add some
notes about it.
Another example.
You can imagine me geeking
out on this, can't you?
I'm collecting data.
It's giving me these
beautiful reports.
Even gives me-- look at that.
Really lovely.
So it's fulfilling all my
paranoid parent desires,
everything I want until one
day, I bought a Nexus 7.
So who has a Nexus 7?
Great.
Amazing device, aren't they?
Really, really good.
So I thought, this is great.
I'm going to set this up
in my child's room.
It will be permanent data
collection device.
This is true.
Thanks, guys.
Good to see you.
Thanks for coming.
So really great.
And then I found there was a
problem because I installed
this but it wasn't configured
correctly, so I had to
configure it.
That was a bit of a nuisance.
Even worse than that, I found
that when I was changing
configuration values on one
device and then looking on the
other device, they wouldn't be
updating, so I would get two
versions of configuration
out of sync.
That's really starting
to get a bit painful.
Even worse than that, the
data wasn't available.
So I was collecting all this
data on one device, I was
collecting all this data on
the other device, and the
reports were not collecting
the data.
So this was really,
really painful
for me, really painful.
And in fact, I'd go as far
as to say this is a bug.
My data is siloed in two
separate places in two
separate devices.
It's not useful to me.
What is this application
doing?
This application is treating
my device as the user.
Don't treat me as a device.
Treat me as a person with
multiple devices.
That's a holistic approach to
who I am and what I'm doing,
and that's what you
want to do.
So Drive is a technology
that solves this.
This is a simple drawing.
I have data in one place, and I
have data in another place.
If I had something in the middle
to synchronize all this
data, then that would
be great.
Drive perfectly solves
this problem.
And there are loads of baby
monitoring software.
This could be the difference
between your software being
5.0 stars or 4.8 stars, and that
makes a huge difference.
So treat the user as a user
holistically, and they will
install your app.
Look, 1,000 results.
I only got through the first
25 before I gave up looking
for one that actually did
what I wanted it to do.
Yay, happy user, me.
Synchronized data.
Of course, just an
aside, Android is
just one part of this.
I've spoken about cross-device
experiences, but obviously
cross-platform.
Now, the Google Drive SDK
is available on any
platform that you have.
Anywhere you can make
an HTTP request, you
can have Google Drive.
Go and check out our
Quickstarts.
Again, you have an application
that works on your Android
device, but how great would it
be if your web version also
had synchronized data?
So that's just an aside.
We're focusing on Android
today, but all
platforms have this.
And multiple devices.
We used to ask the question to
the crowd, who has multiple
devices, and then one
or two people would
stick their hand up.
Who doesn't have multiple
devices?
Seriously, who doesn't have
multiple devices?
You see, my son's mom, who
collects data here, does have
multiple devices and
it's just a thing.
So yeah, everyone has multiple
devices, so cater to people.
And I think this is part
of a general problem.
Where is my data?
Where is it stored?
And specifically in our case,
where are my files?
Now, I was thinking of a good
image to put on this slide and
I was starting to think of
my history of files.
Go back 20 years when I started
collecting PDFs of
medical data, whatever it was.
And I've slowly realized that
I've lost all of that stuff.
Some of it is on a hard drive of
an old laptop that I can't
even find the power supply to.
I'd need to unscrew the thing
and take the hard drive out
and find an adapter and
all this nasty stuff.
It's all lost.
It's all totally,
totally lost.
The last place I want to store
a file is on my hard drive.
I don't know if you guys are
gradually getting into that
same thought.
I just don't want it
on my hard drive.
Even worse than that, I don't
want it on my phone's SD card.
How am I going to get to that?
I've got old phones, I can't
charge them, they won't start,
someone stepped on it.
I just can't get that stuff
out so my files are lost.
Tears is in the rain.
I know, really sad.
It got me really depressed.
I found a sad picture.
So that's that.
Store my data where I need it.
This is somewhat of a plea.
As a user, please store
my data where
I can get it anywhere.
Obviously, the cloud is a
perfect place for that.
Store it somewhere where I
can share it with people,
cross-user applications.
Drive is the perfect
place for that.
Store it somewhere where I can
share it with different
applications.
A file, the abstraction of a
file, is perfect for this.
You have files on
your hard drive.
You share it with other
applications.
Again, Drive extends this
abstraction into the cloud.
You can share your Drive files
with other applications.
So Google Drive.
Store my data where I need
it when I need it.
Especially useful on Android.
Why?
So I could be talking about
any cloud file storage
solution, and you know there are
plenty of them out there.
Why is it especially
useful on Android?
Well, everyone who's got the
phone has already got a Google
account with 5 gigabytes
of storage.
Isn't that obvious?
Doesn't that make sense?
I think that really makes
good strong sense.
Use that storage.
It's there.
They don't have to
sign up again.
You will get one permissions
screen asking for access and
your application can save that
authorization and just use it.
Yay.
No additional sign
up, nothing else.
Use that data.
It's there.
So how do we do it?
I've got a demo for you where I
wrote a couple of things and
I want to show you the demo.
Now, we've had networking
issues, so I actually
recorded the demo.
I'm kind of hoping we don't have
to watch that recording
because it's a bit juttery,
so let's have a look.
Now, the kind of application
I wrote is like a baby data
collection application.
I'll turn it on in a second.
It's nowhere near as good as the
ones you see online, but
it gives you a vague idea.
Hang on.
Yes.
OK, so I'm using a wide network
connection that has
never been tested before, so
we may have to jump to the
video and I'm sorry
about that.
So what is this?
OK, you can see on there, you
can see the various things--
Jigsaw, Banana, Nap.
I've segregated data into
three different types.
Either your baby sleeps
or your baby plays
or your baby eats.
Pretty accurate if you've
got children.
So what am I going to do?
I'm just going to go right
ahead and add,
when should he eat?
Suggestions from the crowd?
AUDIENCE: Steak.
Steak So I add that
there, and look.
It's appeared on the
other device.
Step one done.
[APPLAUSE]
ALI AFSHAR: Thank you.
I told you, we're not breaking
the bounds of modern science,
but imagine if that was the real
Baby ESP as I used it.
I've immediately got the data
synchronized on both my
devices, and we'll talk about
how we do that and what back
end we use for that
in a second.
You see it's going a
bit crazy, so we'll
move straight on.
The other part is
the settings.
Now, this is pretty standard
Settings page that you would
have for an application.
It uses Android's shared
preferences.
Android people know that's a
persistent store by which you
can put some key values
essentially and share them
globally across your
application.
So we're going to go ahead
and we've got to
change some of these.
I'm going to give my son
another middle name.
James I think sounds
pretty good.
And he's moved onto
combination.
So this sometimes takes
a few times.
Why?
Because we're at the mercy of
Android Sync Architecture.
That's a good thing, being at
the mercy of this, but it
might mean that it syncs now.
It might not sync now.
It might sync in 20
minutes time.
Not exactly great
for this demo.
So you can see I'm pressing
the buttons.
Please work, please
work, please work.
If not, I'll just reset
it and do it again.
Let's try again.
Obviously, my implementation is
bad, but I'm going to tell
you the things that I did
and why it's useful.
AUDIENCE: Airplane mode.
ALI AFSHAR: So they told me to
leave it in Airplane mode.
There we go.
So what's happened here is it's
synchronized back to the
original version.
That's a bad bug.
I've got the engineer
in the front row.
There will be beatings,
but you can see.
Let's try just one more time.
Otherwise, I'm going to have
to get you to use your
imaginations.
Again, not good for
geeks, but sorry.
[INAUDIBLE]
for it to work.
Please work, please work.
Ah.
Look at that.
Did anyone notice?
[APPLAUSE]
ALI AFSHAR: So again, we're at
the mercy of the Android Sync
Architecture, so I'm
sorry about that.
So that's the demo, really
two simple things.
We'll switch back to
the presentation.
So that was the demo.
I'm going to talk a bit about
how we did that and how it
relates back to some of the
points I made earlier.
This was the video.
Look, you can see it's a bit
shaky, but we don't have to
watch it, which is good.
So we're storing data here
in two different places.
We have two fundamentally
different paradigms here.
We have one where we're
regularly collecting data that
we can access and use
for reports, for
various things like that.
The other part is application
state, and Google Drive
conveniently has two ways that
you can store data, and they
match up very well with
these two things.
So the first one is AppData,
and this is a feature we
launched recently which gives
you, the developer, a folder
inside the user's Google Drive
and that folder has special
properties that make
it useful for this.
So that's the first part.
The second part is
the actual data.
Now, we can just store that as
a regular file in Drive.
In our case, you can see the
top one, Baby Times DB.
I'm actually storing it as
a Google Spreadsheet.
Now you might think, that's not
really a good solution.
Well, we'll talk about it.
I think it is actually a very
good solution for this.
So we have two different places,
AppData for state and
Google Drive regular files for
actual data, or images, or
notes, or videos, whatever
you want to put in there.
So how does it look?
This is a recent screenshot.
It just shows exactly what we
had there and it's in Google
Spreadsheets.
Remember, put my data
where I need it.
I want to make graphs, I
want to make charts.
I want to do cool things
like that.
I want to be paranoid and really
soak in this thing.
So I think Google Spreadsheets
is a good place to put my
data, then.
But I just want to illustrate
that you don't just have to
use Google Spreadsheets.
It could be a file that
has anything in there.
Now, that says binary
up there.
Obviously, it's not binary.
Does anyone know what
file format that is?
There's a clue.
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: MySQL.
ALI AFSHAR: Well, no.
Close.
So this is a SQLite
3 database.
Why have I mentioned this?
Because actually, when you're
writing Android apps, that's
what you do.
Who's written an Android
app that
collects data of any kind?
OK, so it's pretty easy.
And I wanted to design
the application as
you normally would.
So I create a data schema, it
has a single table, and I just
collect data into that.
That's my app.
That's probably exactly how
Baby ESP works and all the
other data collection
baby apps.
The clever thing, the extra
thing that we do is we ensure
that that data is regularly
synchronized with the Google
Spreadsheet.
You don't want to do
it immediately.
You don't want to send it
straight up the wire.
You want to queue this later for
when the user has access,
when the system decides that
synchronization is
what you want do.
Android is clever how it does
this, how it decides this, so
we let that.
And it also gives you the
benefit of the user being able
to select that check box that
says, do I want to synchronize
this app or not?
Do I want to synchronize
this account or not?
So it's really useful to
use this architecture.
So we write our app normally.
We just have a single table in
our database, three columns,
and that's that, and
the user input goes
straight into there.
So treat it like a local, how
you normally would with
Android, and the rest
will follow.
How do we do the export?
Well now, I'm going to show you
some snippets of really
easy, obvious code.
We use CSV.
I know that's a bit embarrassing
to use CSV for
anything, but actually, it's
really, really useful.
We have a single table and
we want a single sheet.
It's pretty much just CSV.
So how do we get the data out?
We ask for an export link on the
Google spreadsheet and it
gives us a URL by which
we can download CSV.
So we get that, we
parse the CSV.
You notice I didn't put any
commas or quotation marks or
anything crazy in my notes
because that would break my
parser, but that's all
we have for now, so
export it like that.
On the other side, you can give
CSV, you can put it into
Google Drive and you
ask it to convert.
So you say Convert, and Google
Drive is clever enough.
If you're looking at this
snippet, the content variable,
that is something that knows
about the actual content and
the MIME type.
So Google Drive is clever.
It looks at the MIME type text
CSV and it says, well
actually, I can convert
that into a
spreadsheet, so it just does.
So what have I done here
just with this data?
I've made it portable
across devices.
I showed you that.
It's really two devices,
portable data.
But it's not just that.
It's also portable across
applications.
What if this schema
was public?
What if all baby data
applications
used the same schema?
Well then, I could
share my data in
between each one of them.
I know you're smiling.
That's amazing, isn't it?
Now you're talking.
Now you're talking proper
sharing data, making the data
useful, putting it in a
place that is useful.
And finally, just wanted
to mention my wife.
She wants to get involved in
this, so it would be nice if
we can share the single
database.
Sometimes I'm not at home,
sometimes she is, so the data
is now portable across
users as well.
Really, really important,
really useful.
A file on my hard drive, I can't
give that to someone.
I have to attach
it to an email.
It's really bad.
So now let's switch back
over to AppData.
When you save data for your
user as AppData, it
appears like this.
You can see the top row is Baby
Times, the name of the
application, and you can
see that I've got
one kilobyte stored.
It's actually less.
How do we do it?
It's a chunk of JSON
as key value pairs.
They identically reflect the
shared preferences on the
Android device.
It's so simple.
When something changes, we
generate the chunk of JSON, we
push it to the file.
Obviously, it's not
a whole K big.
I think that's the lowest
thing it can say.
What does this allow?
Well, it allows the user to
manage this data, and I'm
going to talk about a couple
of important points with
AppData, and that's, what
can the user do?
So I still strongly believe
the user owns this data.
The user can decide what
they do with it--
so delete it, essentially--
and also see how much
quota it's got.
What they can't do is view this
data and edit the data.
So you might that's a bit evil,
but I don't think it is.
I think it's really useful.
It means the application can
put data in there and make
some assurances that nothing
else, no other applications
can get at the data, no user
can modify the data.
So it's a way of being sure
that the data will have a
certain format or a certain
structure, really useful.
But of course, it uses
up your quota.
So if someone is storing
hundreds of gigabytes in
there, you might think, I'm
going to clear out that app
because it doesn't need all
this data or I might get a
different app.
So those are the things
about AppData folder.
Apart from that, it's just a
regular folder in Drive.
So if anyone's used the Drive
SDK or the Drive API, you know
that there are few operations
that take folder IDs, and in
any situation, you can
use AppData there.
Another really important feature
of this is that the
AppData folder is tied
to a project.
It's a bit of a terminology
issue and I'm sorry about
this, but a project for Google
APIs is something that can
underneath it create
multiple clients.
They're OAuth 2 clients, but
these clients can all work as
if they're the same app.
Why is this useful?
Because you create a different
client for your Android app as
the one you create for your web
app or for your iOS app or
for your installed app.
They're all different clients
but they are part of the same
project, which means your app
data can be accessed from an
application running on one
platform as well as an
application running on another
platform authorized in a
different way.
Very, very powerful.
Again, cross-platform now.
So we've shown you
cross-device.
This is also cross-platform.
Authorization is easy
now on Android.
You parse a scope and you parse
a user account and it
all takes care of it for you.
That's Google Play Services.
Fantastic.
I'm really happy about that.
The scope is a slight thing
I just want to talk about.
When you ask for access to a
user's AppData, you have to
give the special scope.
Two reasons.
The first one is perhaps you
might argue that you could
give access to this with, for
example, the full Drive scope
or other scopes that have access
to read all of Drive.
Well, I disagree and because
people have granted permission
for that already.
If we were to add some ability,
add to the role,
inflate the permissions of this,
then we could be in a
problem because users will be
granting access to something
they hadn't actually explicitly
granted access to.
So that's the first problem.
The second thing is, how great
is it that we have this fine
tuned scope?
Because your application when
they're asking for access
says, I want access to be
able to write and read
configuration data from
Google Drive.
Nothing more, nothing less.
Absolutely perfect.
To the user's much more inclined
to click that button
if they know that it's just a
very, very small scope of
access that you're going
to give them.
So I mentioned the
folder alias.
It's just a regular folder in
Drive, and when you're doing
any operation with files or
folders in Drive, if you can
parse a folder ID, you
can just parse
AppData instead of it.
So this is for creating files,
for moving files from one
folder to another folder, for
searching for files, for
updating files.
Almost any file operation
can take a folder.
So we just parse AppData, and
for the developer, the rest is
entirely transparent.
Of course, this is a real folder
in Drive so it has a
Real ID, and you can actually
use that Real ID if you want
it to be a bit faster.
That's just an optimization that
I would recommend you do.
So a little bit of Java
code, but we'll
just run through this.
We get the shared preferences.
If you've used Android, this
is very common for you.
That actual call gets the shared
preferences for every
activity running in your
application, and then we
subscribe a listener to it.
Really cool feature of the
shared preferences.
This listener just logs
something, but actually, we
respond to this notification by
creating the JSON and then
uploading it.
So we listen to those changes.
I mentioned we use a
SyncerAdapter, and that is
probably the best
way to do it.
Come and have a chat to
[INAUDIBLE] afterwards because
she wrestled with this a bit.
So you create SyncerAdapter.
That defines how you're going
to do the sync, when you're
going to do the sync, that kind
of thing, and it just
takes care of the whole
thing for you.
I think that's really the best
way of doing that, and this is
just an example of the
start of that.
And then we find the correct
file in your AppData folder.
Because this is a folder and
because slightly unhelpfully
here, Google Drive allows you to
have multiple files of the
same name in a folder, so this
implementation is a bit naive.
It does a query.
It looks inside AppData--
if you see AppData
in Parents--
it looks inside there for
the correctly named
file and grabs it.
Obviously, there could be more
than one file so this
implementation just
uses the first.
As I say, slightly naive
but you could
easily improve on that.
So we grab that file.
When we want to upload
new content--
I mentioned this earlier--
we create something that
knows about the data
and the MIME type.
In this case, the MIME type
is Application JSON.
We put it all together and
send it in a single API
request to Drive.
Done.
One API request to
get the data.
Here's this one.
This just grabs the raw data,
just makes an authorized Get
request, and gives it back.
It's really easy.
We've made three API calls
to the Drive API, and
immediately, we have all
this functionality.
We also run this little loop
that detects changes.
So if it's changed locally,
we send the data
to the remote source.
It it's changed in the remote
place, we send the data down
and just upload it.
So this is almost the entire
code to implement this.
Fortunately, [INAUDIBLE]
has released it on GitHub,
so if you want to
use it, grab it.
It's very simple.
You parse a shared preferences
instance to a singleton in the
library and it just does it for
you, synchronizes all your
shared preferences.
I suggest you have a
look at the code.
You could extend it, you could
throw it away, you could do
whatever you like with it.
But it's there and I suggest
everyone has a look at that.
I hope throughout this talk,
I've somehow got across to you
that it's not just about
baby monitors.
I hope.
I know I added this later
because I was thinking, hang
on, do people just think I'm
talking about baby monitors?
Anything, any file you have,
any data that you create, I
think you should put that in a
place where the user wants it.
You should put that
in Google Drive.
You're taking notes, you're
making images, you're
modifying images, you're
downloading videos, you're
uploading videos.
Anything that involves a file,
put that data somewhere where
it's useful.
Put the data where I want it.
When I'm in the supermarket
looking, I wonder which food
my child likes the most?
I know, I'll check.
Put that data where I want it.
This is a plea from
me as a user.
Please treat me as a user.
Treat your users as users.
Don't treat the individual
device as a user.
You've got to stop planning
your applications to be
resistant to changes in device,
changes in location.
Your applications
really must do--
I think not to do that now when
all the technology is
available, I think it's a bug.
I really do.
And I think if you do that,
you will create your
cross-platform, cross-device,
seamless experiences, and I
think Google Drive is
a way to do that.
So my challenge to you guys,
please, go ahead.
Do these.
Make these seamless
applications.
Everyone will thank you.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ALI AFSHAR: Questions?
Oh I should say, before the
questions, I'll be available
on the Chrome and Apps Sandbox
on Level Three if you want a
longer question or you don't
feel like getting up in front
of this crowd and talking.
AUDIENCE: OK, question.
How does the shared data get
deleted from Google Drive if
somebody uninstalls the app?
Does that data just live
there forever?
ALI AFSHAR: So when you
uninstall an app, we have a
nice flow there.
The user is prompted to say,
this app still has some hidden
application data.
Would you like to delete
it or not?
So we cover that case.
You might consider an instance
where you say, I don't want
this app installed but I want
to keep the data around in
case one day I do install it
again, so that's a case, but
we cover that.
But the user is prompted, delete
this data if you're
going to uninstall the app.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: This isn't a question,
it's just a tip.
For a really good example of
an app developed by one guy
who does this, Sleep As Android
is a sleep data
collection tool with a plug-in
called Stats As Android which
gives you the charts inside the
app but uses Spreadsheets
for the raw data.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, uses Google
Spreadsheets or--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, uses Google
Spreadsheets.
ALI AFSHAR: Wow, OK.
AUDIENCE: So if anybody wants
to see an example, that's an
app that might be worth--
ALI AFSHAR: So I wish you'd
have told me this before
because that would have saved
me writing an app.
But thank you, Sleep
As Android.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In terms of compliance and
thinking about Google Apps
Enterprise, could it be possible
for me to have the
control over that configuration
file to make
revision and inspecting that
file for compliance purposes?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, so you're
talking about the
configuration file in AppData?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because--
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
Sorry, go on.
AUDIENCE: Because I saw that
you can't actually view or
delete the contents for
the file, but--
ALI AFSHAR: So the user can't
but the developer can.
So the application can.
And it's a regular file
in Drive, so it has
all the other features.
You can't share it.
That's one feature
it doesn't have.
But you can look at revision
history and
other things like that.
So actually, this is a nice
version file in your Drive.
It's useful and definitely
covers that case.
AUDIENCE: What happens if two
users modify at the same time?
How do you handle the
conflicts on Drive?
ALI AFSHAR: So you don't and
the world just explodes.
So in this use case-- and I
specifically avoided this.
So two things.
One, we don't really cover it.
The last change wins in this
case, and that's not exactly
good for this.
But if you look at the use case,
I'm not really going to
go around with two devices, one
device in one hand and one
device in another hand and
start changing the
configuration.
It might happen that we're
collecting data.
So I don't think that
particularly
fits the use case.
But what we do have is this
awesome product called the
Real Time API.
Anyone heard of this or seen
the Real Time API?
So this is specifically designed
for that use case.
I suggest you go and
read about it.
It provides all the conflict
resolution, all the updating,
everything there.
And we have a session
about that--
AUDIENCE: Tomorrow!
ALI AFSHAR: Tomorrow.
So we have a session.
So please come along.
Two of the hardcore engineers
are going to tell you how it
works, so that's exciting.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALI AFSHAR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I want to ask a question.
What can you do for the
interconnection of Google
Drive and Microsoft
Office 365?
What's [INAUDIBLE]?
ALI AFSHAR: So we had this chat
earlier today, but I'll
just go over what we said.
So this gentleman is very
interested in writing some
kind of an interconnection
software between Google Drive
and Office 365.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: API can just transfer
documents in one
direction, cannot--
ALI AFSHAR: So the Google Drive
API allows you to import
and export data.
So it's a two-way
data transfer.
And the formats that we use,
we have some proprietary
formats that belong
to Microsoft--
for example, DocX and
this kind of thing--
which I think would
be perfect for
interfacing with Office 365.
But there are other formats.
I showed you CSV.
There's HTML, of course, import
and export from there,
PDF, various formats, all
the Open Office formats.
So I think you can write
that connector.
I don't think you're going
to have a problem there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
to an IETF [INAUDIBLE]
and about today's topic.
Please pay more attention to--
ALI AFSHAR: Sure, sure.
So you've got my
email address.
We'll keep talking about this.
Don't worry.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALI AFSHAR: Thank you.
Any other questions?
Brilliant.
Thank you for coming.
Come and chat to me later.
Oh, you've got a question.
Sorry.
Hold the applause.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So actually, there are
two questions.
One is, are you planning some
support in terms of patterns
or APIs for third party, like
iOS or Microsoft Stack apps,
to use Google Drive?
Second question is, if I write
an app and I want to give the
user both the privacy of they're
on Google Drive, but
still I would want to cover the
quota of them, you know
what I mean, so I don't run into
trouble when they hit the
five gigabyte limit?
ALI AFSHAR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is there
anything you're
thinking about about that?
ALI AFSHAR: So let's start with
the first question first.
Essentially, yes.
We want to make the experience
as easy as possible.
We launched the Drive API
actually a year ago, so still
at the moment, it's
pretty raw state.
We're still trying to work
out the use cases.
And of course, in an ideal
world-- and I can't really
comment on our future plans--
but in an ideal world if
priorities were logically
designed, yes.
We would have libraries that
make it crazy easy, as my
colleague Stephen says, crazy
easy to do this stuff.
Just a single call,
nothing else.
So it's definitely
in our plans.
We want that to be as
simple as possible.
Second question.
AUDIENCE: It was about the
quota and the app.
Who owns the quota and if the
app owner can take over that.
ALI AFSHAR: So I'm quite
strongly of the belief that
this is the user's
data and the user
should pay for the quota.
Actually, the smart people in
the audience will notice that
this application didn't cost
the user any quota because
it's using Google Spreadsheets
as a back end, which can be as
big as you like and they don't
take up any quota.
So I'm not suggesting that you
go out and do that, but this
app doesn't use any of
the user's quota.
It uses one kilobyte, and
you know that's nothing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALI AFSHAR: Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.